for any filmmaker who would love a
career that the two of you had work a
what kind of work would they be prepared
to put in and be what kind of sacrifices
would they have to make that's that's a
good question
I don't think that you can approach what
mark and I do as with the idea of having
the kind of career that we have I think
the only reason we have the kind of
career that we have is because we just
make stuff and we have always just made
stuff and made stuff that we think is
new and special and and is uniquely ours
to give you know
and luckily other people want to watch
that stuff and networks and studios are
willing to pay for that stuff now but it
took a good 12 years before anybody
wanted to watch it or pay for it and I
think the only reason we're here is
because we love doing it and we love
each other and we it's just it's almost
like a can't not do it type of thing and
you know we were lucky enough to to have
it have it be supported now I mean it's
happening with Joe Swanberg right now I
mean Joe made movies from love and made
tons of them because he loved it and he
loved the process and he loved creating
with other people and sharing it and
exposing himself in every way and and
now he's supported you know and I think
that's it's not really a model but I
guess it is you know it's you can't want
it for the career you gotta want it for
the love of it and the art of it and you
got to be willing to do it whether you
get paid or not so it sounds like to
that same idea going back to that
conversation you had a year and a half
ago
Jay Davis about his idea that he just
could not not do it yeah I do yeah I
mean Jays not making the Manson family
vacation because he thinks is a good
career move it's actually a bad career
move for him because he's like you know
he's doing another job and he's got two
kids and it's it's you know it's a
really big strain on everything in its
life to try and pull this thing off he's
doing it because he loves it and he has
to do it there's something inside of him
that's trying to get out and and and
that's I relate to that process that's
been the process of my entire career and
and you know it just so happens that I
love the idea and I loved what he's
doing so it's it's easy for me to get
behind it and support it
you